on va maintenant au brésil à deux mois
des élections présidentielles jaillir
ball sonar au demande la destitution du
juge de la cour suprême qui a ouvert une
enquête contre lui le chef de l'état
brésilien est visé par une procédure
pour diffusion de fausses informations
sur le système de vote électronique
explications de boue stallone a redit
le président jacques bolson aroa démarre
dès ce vendredi au sénat d'ouvrir une
procédure de destitution à l'encontre
d'alexandre de moraes la d11 juge de la
cour suprême en brésil une décision qui
pousse plus loin la passe d'armes entre
le chef d'état à la justice brésilienne
il a pris cette décision dans la suite
d'une requête du tribunal supérieur
électoral qui avait annoncé ouvrir une
enquête contre le chef d'état pour je
cite abus de pouvoir politique et
économique dans ses attaques contre le
système de vote électronique et la
légitimité des élections de 2022
en cause un facebook live au cours
duquel bolton arrow assure qu'il existe
de fraude dans le système d'urnes
électroniques en vigueur depuis
1996 au brésil sans apporter la moindre
preuve pour la justice brésilienne issa
juin il s'agirait tout simplement de
fausses informations shy'm also know qui
devrait briguer une réélection ne
préconise pas au retour aux votes par
bulletins papier mais l'impression de
reçus après chaque vote électronique
afin de permettre un recomptage des voix
un cas de contestation ces accusations
du président interviennent alors qu'il
est au plus bas dans les sondages ball
solaro est donné depuis plusieurs
semaines largement perdant face à l'ex
président de gauche luiz inacio lula da
silva si celui-ci décidé de se
représente